on va parler de marine le pen qui vient
de sortir son nouveau clip de campagne
sauf que les paysages de sa vidéo
ressemble beaucoup au clip du groupe pl
[Musique]
en fait on s'est amusé à mélanger les
deux regardez même si vous ne connaissez
pas pnl même si vous ne connaissez pas
marine le pen
normalement ça doit ouverte et revient
de si loin que je me souvienne j'ai
toujours ressenti un attachement
viscéral passionnel à notre pays n'ont
pas d'amis
pourtant j'aime du plus profond de mon
coeur n'est plus profond de mon âme
cette nation millénaire qui ne se soumet
pas
je pense qu'on sera dans dix ans je suis
intensément fièrement fidèlement
évidemment française je veux que les
français puissent vivre leur rêve dans
une france juste
c'est tout le sens de mon engagement
c'est ce pourquoi je me bats à weight of
program pacult on ferme sa gueule
[Applaudissements]